so using documentary filmmaking in this
form of activism what do you want people
to see about the Whitey Bulger case yeah
you know you have to be a little careful
about just saying documentaries are an
advocacy tool of course they are but I
think you can't just be an advocate you
also have to be a storyteller and
certain people make films for different
reasons and certainly storytelling and
cinema for the sake of cinema which i
think is a dying art in some ways is
certainly a valid reason to make films
you know so all of those are present in
anything I undertake but the thing I
want people to walk away from with
regard to the Whitey Bulger film is that
I think the true story of what enabled
Bulger to reign over a criminal empire
for 25 years without even so much as
being stopped for a traffic ticket I
think that real story hasn't been told
and just because Bulger has been
convicted which is good he deserves to
be convicted the film is not an apology
for Whitey Bulger he's a brutal vicious
killer that deserves to be behind bars
but what enabled him to reign there's a
level of corruption in my opinion a
corruption of our institutions of
justice that needs to be looked at
because we can't allow this to happen
again and when Carmen Ortiz who is the
US Attorney for the District of
Massachusetts at the end of the Bulger
trial and you see this moment at the end
of our film stands before the assembled
press that was covering the trial and
said with the conviction of James Whitey
Bulger this ugly chapter in Boston's
history is now we hope it can be closed
paraphrasing somewhat but in my opinion
how can we close this chapter if we
don't know who was responsible for
allowing Bulger to kill
and if you believe he was an FBI
informant as is the conventional story
it's bad enough that institutionally
they look the other way as he killed and
did all sorts of terrible things while
an FBI informant but as the film
demonstrates there are some troubling
aspects to whether or not he really was
an informant and so if his protection as
a criminal afforded to him by some
people in the FBI and the Department of
Justice was not as the result of being
an informant but through some other
deeper level of corruption then we
really need to know how that happened
and all of this is because I think and
the main message I want to get out in
this film or the main activism is that I
think the families of victims whether
they were some of the victims were
fellow criminals but some of the victims
were innocent bystanders and in one case
Roger wheel or a very successful
legitimate businessman gunned down in a
country club in Oklahoma you know these
families of victims regardless of what
whether they were a criminal or a legit
businessman the families of these
victims deserve answers as to how their
loved ones were allowed to be killed by
a criminal who should have been brought
in to justice much earlier I don't
believe you know agencies of the
government should be allowed to pick and
choose who should live and who should
die in their zeal to bring down the
Italian mafia they look the other way
again whether he was an informant or not
an informant which is one of the central
questions of the film in both scenarios
he was allowed to kill while the FBI and
the Department of Justice focused on
bringing down
mafia and so they decided that was the
goal to bring down the Italian mafia and
in Boston we're gonna look the other way
as to what the Italian sorry as to what
the Irish gangsters are gonna do here
and I don't think the government should
be in that business allowing certain
people to you know get away with
criminality while they you know close
down others
you